bonjour à tous nous sommes lundi 11
juillet il est 10 heures du matin nous
sommes à l'aérodrome de chartres dans
l'eure à un peu plus de 80 km de paris
et plus précisément de l'arc de triomphe
des champs elysées c'est là que vont
défiler les troupes militaires
françaises pour le défilé du 14 juillet
aujourd'hui pour figaro live nous allons
participer à la répétition générale de
ce défilé et nous allons donc prendre
part à bord de l'un des 12 hélicoptères
de l'aviation légère de l'armée de terre
française
au programme rapide brief sécurité et
rapide brive sur les conditions de météo
qui ont l'art excellente aujourd'hui
rencontre avec les pilotes l'équipage et
deux heures de vol au dessus de paris je
vous propose de vivre cette journée avec
nous c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est plus à tenter le passage de papa 5
je vous confirme les oreilles à la
tribune présidentielle papa de sela plus
triomphé dans l'articulation force des
régiments écouteurs de combat donc le
caïman poker 43 et le centre de paris et
ensuite si vous avez une panne mais plus
ça va et au but
une heure avant le bâillon
la cape temps ci et pour que la france
est
n'a pas de
[Musique]
donc là le brief vient de se terminer
nous on va embarquer à bord d'un puma le
puma c'est un hélicoptère de manoeuvre
et dassault qui est surtout utilisée sur
le territoire national on va aller
rencontrer notre commandant de bord
bonjour lieutenant-colonel bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous accueillir est-ce que
vous pouvez nous nous présenter un petit
peu cet engin ce puma d'écouté c'est un
hélicoptère puma c'est ce qu'on appelle
un hélicoptère de manoeuvre et dassault
un hélicoptère qui a pour vocation de
transporter du personnel en général une
dizaine de personnes mais c'est assez
variable c'est un hélicoptère
relativement ancien et date des années
60 c'est un hélicoptère de combat dans
le sens où il a vocation à être engagée
au plus près de l'action mais ce n'est
pas un hélicoptère de ce qu'on appelle
des hélicoptères armés c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas pour vocation d'être armé
et de délivrer des munitions de délivrer
le feu au sol voilà sa fonction de
combat et de transporter et d'insérer ou
d'extraire des commandos au plus près de
l'action alors là on est en train d'être
interrompue parce que justement il ya le
plein qui est en train d'être fait juste
avant le vol je vous laisse ce peut-être
nous raconte nous expliquer ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire précisément bien
coûter pour aller défiler une nous faut
du kérosène donc il faut mettre du
kérosène est assez de kérosène pour
pouvoir défiler et prévoir tous les
temps d'attentes qui sont nécessaires
donc on fait un plein qui est calculée
en fonction de la masse emporté du temps
de vol dont on a besoin et c'est pour ça
que les pleins sont faits au dernier
moment pour qu'il corresponde à la
mission alors on est à quelques minutes
du décollage on va rencontrer le chef de
corps du 1er régiment d'hélicoptères de
combat bonjour le bonjour colonel
pourquoi c'est important de faire une
répétition grandeur nature comme ça
trois jours avant avant l'événement on
va écouter
le rendez vous d'un régiment qui
défilent le 14 juillet devant la
population française devant le président
république ça manque est important donc
on veut que ce soit beau que ce soit une
réussite et c'est ce qui justifie qu'on
s'y prépare sérieusement avec rigueur
mais c'est vraiment une mise à l'honneur
du régime en queue de défilé le jour du
14 juillet pour eux nous militaires ça
compte beaucoup
se présenter devant notre chef le
président la république c'est un grand
honneur voilà et donc oui tout le monde
ici est très fier sachant que la plupart
des équipages qui sont présents
aujourd'hui était il y a peu de temps au
sel en train de se battre
contre les groupes armés terroristes en
appui des pays partenaires qu'on a dans
la région donc oui pour eux bruce est
très important merci beaucoup écouté non
je vous en prie et je vous souhaite
maintenant un excellent envol merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
aucun
matériel
à
4-2
les prout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc là il est 15h30 on vient tout juste
d'atterrir un chat pour nous ça s'est
super bien passé on va demander au
pilote directement comment comment vous
vous êtes senti pendant pendant ces deux
heures de vol à peu près donc vers paris
écoutez ça s'est très bien passé je
pense qu'on était bien dans le timing au
passage ces champs elysées avec une
belle formation donc je pense c'est une
répétition qui est plutôt réussie c'est
des vols qu'on n'a pas du tout
l'habitude de faire parce que d'habitude
on vole plus tôt près du sol avec des
aéronefs qui suit pas les mêmes
trajectoires là la particularité c'est
qu'il faut obtenir la formation par
rapport aux hélicoptères qui sont devant
nous et également par rapport aux
hélicoptères qui sont à nos côtés donc
c'est c'est plutôt technique à faire
mais c'est assez sympa comment vous
faites pour arriver à la seconde près au
niveau de la tribune présidentielle le
jour j alors on a la chance d'avoir un
hélicoptère qui est assez modernes
équipés de gps et de beaucoup de
systèmes qui nous permette d'arriver à
la seconde près à sur l'objectif merci
beaucoup je remercie
donc à on est avec le lieutenant colonel
armand et on va visiter l'hélicoptère
voir un peu comment ça s'organise à
l'intérieur donc à l'intérieur comme
vous le voyez il ya une partie avant une
partie arrière la partie soute un peu
comme dans un avion la partie qui sert à
transporter tout le monde avec la
particularité c'est que dans la partie
arrière tout à l'arrière vous avez tous
les équipements radio qui sont déportés
de l'avant et bien sûr à l'avant nous
avons le cockpit le poste de pilotage là
où tout se passe
alors dites nous un peu comment commence
à s'organiser il ya plein de touche
partout quand comment vous faites pour
piloter un tel engin alors de façon
générale vous avez cette commande
qu'elle pas cyclique qui va influer en
profondeur et sur la gauche et sur la
droite cette commande qui est le parent
général qui va permettre de monter des
sens qu'ils donnent delà de la puissance
ici vous avez tous les paramètres moteur
que ce soit la pression les temps des
températures ici vous avez tous les
paramètres de vol donc les écrans sont
éteints mais
vous avez tout ce qui est cap altimétrie
montée ou descente tout ce qui est
radionavigation
en bas vous avez tout ce qui est radar
pilote automatique et tout ce qui est
communication se retrouve complètement
en bas
ici vous avez toutes les radios qui nous
permet de communiquer en vol voilà poids
particulier vous avez ici un petit gps
qui nous aident et là ce qu'on appelle
un pavé de voyants d'alarmé donc c'est
le ce sont les voyants qu'ils ne doivent
pas être allumées lorsque nous sommes en
vol ok merci beaucoup voilà il est 16h
tout s'est très bien passé les équipages
sont en train de terminer le matériel
les commandants de bord et les pilotes
eux sont au débriefing et si tout s'est
bien passé et bien rendez vous le 14
juillet à l'arc de triomphe